[Music]
from croissant stuffers to festive
pizzas to gingerbread lattes we wanted
to find out all of the fast food
christmas menu items in the uk japan and
the us this is food wars
here in the uk we have several festive
drink options at starbucks all of which
are hot we'll start with this one which
is the very festive gingerbread latte
i'll do a joe and try and sip all of
these
actually not bad next up we have this
one which is a caramel waffle latte then
we have this one which is a fudge
brownie hot chocolate
oh
oh i don't like that that's bad
we also have this one which is a toffee
not latte a toffee or nuts particularly
christmassy i'm not really convinced
it's very nutty that is nasty then
finally we have this one which is a
venti eggnog latte i think the last time
i tried eggnog was actually our last
christmas special and i haven't touched
it since i've kind of forgotten
everything about it i'll try it again
no what
this isn't a british thing the people in
america actually drink eggnog if you
want to get your starbucks fixed at home
then uk starbucks also offer beans these
come in the form of a christmas roast
and also a blonde christmas roast so we
have lots of delicious starbucks holiday
drinks such as gingerbread latte
this is perfect for winter season it
warms me up
not only my body but also my heart
you should definitely try this next one
toasted white chocolate frappuccino
it's a little bit sweet but i would say
it's very good
every santa claus would love this we've
got toasted white chocolate mocha
itadakimasu
i'd say it's totally the same as this
one
but that means it's very good
and last one we've got crown broly
lottery
it's so sweet
it's too sweet
we also have the three whole coffee bean
options we've got christmas blend
and christmas blonde roast
and christmas espresso roast
take a look at this it says christmas
blah blah blah
but it's not christmassy at all
starbucks you should make it more
christmasy just like this
this
this is so perfect and in the u.s our
holiday starbucks drinks include all of
these you know what we're doing
first one of course is the venti creme
brulee latte i like creme brulee let's
make it a latte
[Music]
yeah that's very good toasted white
chocolate mocha
holy
that might be the best one
that's the one to beat irish cream cold
brew
whoa first mess mm-hmm all right next
one a sugar cookie almond milk latte
iced
everything like settled to the bottom
nope yeah that's okay chestnut pralings
latte does anyone know what a prank
language is
i don't
well whatever it is it's good yo
starbucks is on it this year they did
not have a peppermint mocha and the
starbucks we went to unfortunately but
that is also available also starbucks
you can get the bean blends to go we
have the peppermint mocha blend have the
christmas blend and the holiday blend
one holiday drink to look out for in the
uk is the venti eggnog latte one of
these contains 476 calories as well as a
whopping 54 grams of added sugar please
in the us we have three holiday drinks
that have 60 grams or more of added
sugar the venti creme brulee latte rocks
60 grams of added sugar while the venti
peppermint mocha has 68 grams of added
sugar and the venti toasted white
chocolate mocha has
69 grams of sugar
69 careful santa can read your thoughts
that means at least
two drinks during the holiday season
make the fourth and fifth most sugary
drinks on the starbucks menu japanese
starbucks didn't tell me how much sugar
is in these christmas drinks but we do
have a calorie count a vintage
gingerbread latte has 488 calories an
event creme brulee latte has 497
calories and tall toasted white
chocolate frappuccino is 403 calories
the most calories outward goes to the
venti toasted white chocolate mocha it
has 616 calories
what have you done
very good
what about the food well in the uk we
have a bunch of new items as well as
some classic favorites first up we have
this one the festive feast panini next
up is the tis the season turkey sandwich
two new additions include a chocolate
and orange s'mores toasty as well as a
blue cheese and chutney toastie our last
two sandwiches are a toasty to be
thankful for lots going on and then
finally a very merry beyond meat
sandwich then we went to some of the
baked options starting with my favorite
south pole sam he's making a return he
was in the last episode i love him he's
still my son look at him he's adorable
how could you eat this come on look at
him not only is south paul sam still on
the menu but he's been really busy this
year because he's come back with a
girlfriend
this is north pole nat
maybe he's supposed to be a polar bear
not 100 sure so not only is it kind of a
forbidden romance it's also a very long
distance relationship between syllabus
um and north pole nap but their love is
just that strong it carries them through
and i for one really hope it works out
for them in less adorable but still very
delicious news the christmas tree
brownie is back at starbucks in the uk
another returning favorite is the
cranberry muffin it's basically just a
cranberry muffin with i think some
either icing or custard in the middle
it's pretty good
then we have two new additions starting
with the toffee nut latte cupcake this
is like a coffee flavored cupcake topped
with some chopped nuts and a chocolate
star
and finally we have a red velvet loaf
cake
as the name suggests it's a red velvet
loaf and then it's topped with some
icing as well as some very festive
colored sprinkles in japan we have
several sweet holiday options which are
a cranberry bliss bar and a chocolate
pound cake
they also have gingerbread cookies and a
stolen which are currently unavailable
so sad a stolen is a classic holiday
bread with red cranberries green
pistachios
white powdered sugar raisins almonds
walnuts orange peels and marzipan and
also you can get a holiday cheesecake
baked cheese tart and a chocolate fresh
cake but online order only
it's a new era
it's not like grandma's cookies
here in the us get yourself a reindeer
cake pop this little guy right here
[Music]
turns out he's delicious
snowman cooking
personal favorite cranberry bliss bar
now you can get a slice of the bar or
the bar tray to go and also this year
they have the sugar plum cheese danish
which the starbucks we went to did not
have unfortunately
in the uk our kfc exclusives are mostly
focused on the gravy first up we've got
this gravy burger box meal this comes
with a gravy burger a chicken tender to
dip a side of fries and a side of gravy
if you're wondering what a gravy burger
is it's basically a chicken sandwich
with some cheese and some gravy mayo but
then it's also got this hash brown on
top into which they've kind of pressed a
circular divot the idea is that you pour
more gravy on top of it it kind of holds
it in there so that when you bite into
it you get a lot of gravy in your bite
so i've poured a small amount of gravy
as you can see it's holding it nicely in
place but we're not here for a small
amount of gravy and food wars
now that is a gravy burger
if that's somehow not enough gravy for
you you can also get a range of gravy
bucket meals from a uk kfc firstly you
can get a double gravy bucket meal which
contains six pieces of chicken a large
drink four orders of gravy four orders
of fries one order of popcorn chicken
and then you can choose between either
eight hot wings or six boneless chicken
strips if you don't want to choose
between the wings or the strips you can
also upgrade to a triple bucket meal
which contains them both for a
reasonable price of 23 pounds 99 pence
also i know that's only three orders of
gravy instead of four but one of them
exploded in the delivery transit now
we're guessing that the bucket meals
aren't designed to be eaten by one
person but the box meal definitely is
one of these box meals contains 1075
calories which is 53.75 percent of your
daily allowance there's also 107.8 of
your daily sodium in here one culprit
for the high sodium might be the gravy
according to kfc one portion of the
gravy contains 480 milligrams of sodium
which is around 20 of the total meals
value
kfc is very popular in japan around
christmas time ever since the 70s kfc
has been a part of the christmas
tradition in japan because of a popular
kfc marketing campaign called
krishnaseniwa kentucky or kentucky for
christmas and now it's become so normal
to have kfc on christmas and also very
small percentage of japanese people are
christians so christmas is just fun
event to spend with your family or if
you're dating you spend christmas with
your boyfriend or girlfriend and now
even now i'm still looking for the one
who can enjoy christmas with me
message me
i'm on a nice list
since kfc for christmas is so popular
kfc requires you to reserve your
christmas specials weeks in advance to
be picked up closer to christmas
unfortunately at the time of this
recording the food isn't yet available
i wanted to try them so kfc offers 30
barrels which are either an 8-piece
original chicken or a four-piece
original chicken with four chicken
tenders
both barrel meals include a minced
chicken lasagna glasses chocolate cake
and seasonal buckets and plates
wow
and also you can get roast chicken and
gravy and roasted garlic thighs and
chicken breast with cheese sauce and
barbecue chicken oh by the way if you
haven't watched kfc episode usa vs japan
you should definitely watch
watch watch after watching this video
here in the u.s kfc for a very limited
time and it totally got past me is a
very slick very cool finger licking
chicken mitten bucket hugger apparently
had to pre-order one by like before
november 13th anyway it's a knitted
sweater like i don't know koozie for
your kfc bucket it has mittens sewn into
it it is hilarious couldn't get my hands
on one but if we can have someone in
graphics go ahead and just uh put it on
there for me
yeah
that's what it looks like pretty cool
huh what is available in much larger
quantities is this the kfc festive
design christmas bucket
even has a little
top there is not fun
in the uk mcdonald's is featuring two
sandwich options for christmas a festive
stack and also a festive crispy chicken
sandwich in the uk the festive stack
contains some beef patties some cheddar
cheese a white cheese sauce some bacon
some lettuce as well as some red onions
whereas the festive crispy chicken is a
crispy chicken patty with some bacon
some cheddar cheese i think there's some
sage and onion mayo in there as well as
some cranberry sauce mcdonald's in the
uk has one festive side and it's these
cheese melt dippers these are little
discs of camembert cheese which are then
breaded and fried and they look and
smell really good i gotta say and they
also come with this tangy tomato sauce
which also looks pretty good i think
it's just kind of like a fancy ketchup
then we have two dessert options
including a celebrations mcflurry and a
festive pie i'll get into a little bit
more detail on celebrations later but
what it is is a selection box in the uk
it's all of the kind of mars brand candy
so it's things like snickers and
maltesers and they put little bits of
them into a mcflurry and it's pretty
good the festive pie is basically the
apple pie shell but instead of the apple
filling it comes with a minced meat and
custard filling now for those of you who
aren't versed in stunning british
cuisine mince meat is not actually beef
please don't freak out we're not putting
beef and custard together that would be
weird mincemeat in the festive context
refers to a mixture of fruits things
like raisins little pieces of apple and
things like that which are simmered down
in some sugar to create a kind of sweet
fruity mixture and then add it to things
like this or mince pies then finally we
have two hot drink options we have a
choco fudge latte and our final seasonal
mcdonald's item is this hot chocolate
deluxe in the u.s our mcdonald's only
has one exclusive drink the peppermint
mocha which unfortunately was not
available when we went to that
mcdonald's to get it what they did have
thankfully is this holiday pie
i don't know what's in it mystery pie
about to be solved
it tastes exactly like a sugar cookie
very disappointing in the us and the uk
from december 13th to christmas eve
mcdonald's has partnered up with the
queen of christmas music that's right
mariah carey for the mariah menu check
this out
see that starting on the 13th if you
spend over one dollar on the mcdonald's
app there will be an exclusive free menu
item you can have it's nice it's kind of
like a mcdonald's advent calendar pretty
good idea
japan mcdonald's is offering two
exclusive nugget dipping sauces from now
until next year we've got
lobster and tomato cream sauce
in a nutshell
this is so good it's got strong lobster
flavor
10 out of 10.
thank you
let's try kokuma steak sauce so coco
means richness and uma is deliciousness
and this steak sauce is a japanese style
steak sauce based on soy sauce
[Music]
this is so good i could eat rice with
this
like forever these new exclusive sauces
santa claus love them
in the uk pizza hut only has one festive
offering and it's this one
the hog roast pizza this is topped with
pulled pork red onion a sage and onion
stuffing and an applesauce drizzle i'm
really intrigued by the applesauce
drizzle so i'm gonna have to give this a
try
honestly i'm kind of impressed by this i
thought the apple sauce would ruin it
because i don't normally want sweet
things on my pizza but yeah it kind of
all works whole grains pizza does what
it says on the tin our pizza in the us
is offering this very festive triple
treat box now what this is is a box
obviously with two medium one topping
pizzas five bread sticks and cinnabon
minerals a plus for presentation with
pizza hut wait a second what
oh
this is not what's on the website this
there was a thing that had like
shelves and stuff show what it looks
like on the website
this is like three pizza boxes i am so
mad that this is what they did this is
not at all what i thought this was going
to be so everyone can see
how disappointing this is oh this looks
all beat up and stuff
the whole point was it's supposed to be
like a fun box this isn't that fun this
is regular
ba hamburg
we have a special deal based on pizza
hut mascots kazoo and merc
kazu is one of the most famous comedians
in japan and also mook
is one of the most famous characters in
japan and recently they have been
appointed as pizza hut's ambassadors and
this christmas you can get kazoo and mix
blissful half and half pizza
one half is for kaiju's favorite
camembert and mozzarella and another
half is for mook's favorite
meat sauce pixelized iberico and
margarita
and also you can get the family side set
with this pizza that includes a chicken
combo set wow
festive
in the uk domino's has one christmas
pizza and it's called the festive one
this one comes with sage and onion
marinated turkey breast some bacon some
sausage and some onion let's try it out
a little bit dry maybe maybe domino's
can redeem themselves with these after
eight cookies for those of you who don't
know after eights are a chocolate and
mint combination which are generally
kind of eaten at the end of dinner
parties that was the marketing back in
the day uh obviously we are filming this
before 8 p.m so it's not a strictly
enforced rule let's give these a try
okay yeah these are actually really good
it tastes exactly like the after eight
filling as i guess i'd expect um yeah
just like a really good dark chocolate
and mint cookie our dominoes offer the
christmas premium cuatro which is
separated into four sections we have
smoked chicken with basil sauce
charcoal roast beef
italian juicy roast pork and shrimp and
scallop with crab sauce
for dessert we've got a cool milk grate
this is what it looks like
it's actually a huge one not only these
but also dominoes will be offering
premium rose chicken soon it's gonna be
festive
subway in the uk is featuring something
called a tiger pig sandwich for
christmas this year it's basically a
giant pig in a blanket in a row so a pig
in a blanket in the uk is not the same
as is in the u.s in the uk it is a
sausage wrapped in bacon whereas in the
u.s i think it's like a hot dog in
pastry that is correct harry in the us
our pigs in a blanket are normally like
tiny hot dogs wrapped in like croissant
dough
and they're usually like hors d'oeuvres
or what picky kids eat at holiday
parties so that looks
real gross
another festive sandwich filling from
the uk subway is brie cheese and then
finally we have a festive dessert option
at uk subways which is a chocolate
orange cookie chocolate and orange are a
really popular combination around
christmas time in the uk i'm not really
sure where it originated from but
there's a brand called terry's chocolate
orange who do these kind of like balls
of chocolate and orange those are super
popular around christmas time i think
this is subway's attempt to kind of get
in on the act there
now one christmas tradition we have in
the uk when it comes to suites are
selection boxes these are little tubs
filled with small suites usually all
from one brand so for example you have
heroes which are owned by cadbury or you
have celebrations which are owned by
mars i'm not sure where the association
between christmas and selection boxes
started in the uk but i know it's been
going on for years because i think
quality street and roses in particular
have been around for decades one last
thing to check before i hand over is the
content of the quality street in it's
become quite a divisive topic in the uk
recently because people feel short
changed when they don't get enough of
the good ones in there i think the good
ones are generally considered to be like
the purple ones maybe the green
triangles so let's count them out and
see how many we're actually getting
[Music]
so we got four green triangles five of
the orange chocolate crunch six of the
caramel sticks six of the toffee pennies
seven of the orange creams eight of the
fudge five of the purple ones five of
the milk choc blocks eight of the
caramel swirls six of the coconut
eclairs and seven of the strawberry
delights make of that what you will in
the u.s just about every candy brand has
a christmasy themed candy flavor shape
and or package there are too many name
in this video so i just went ahead with
some of the hits we got
a
reese's peanut butter
snowman reese's
holiday lights
how do you think this is do you think
it's actually on a string it's not
what
what they're cooking they're wrong but
they're connected by like a string like
lights right and this gave me these
they're just chocolate eggs thank you
reeses you are on the naughty list which
is peanut butter trees this is kind of
like a rorschach test what do you see
i bet i bet nobody said tree
this is sooner to be my parents fighting
than it is a tree
as far as what i see in here
nutcracker shape i mean everything's
suspect now
okay they actually did it congrats you
got one right
i also have white trees
one exclusive
is reese's peanut butter cups peanut
brittle
i just saw these at target on the fly
they got gingerbread cookie
kitkats here in the u.s oreos oreos
oreos you get yourself a white fudge
covered oreo so i guess that's supposed
to be snow gingerbread oreos
m m's m m's m m's so m m's has this year
they're doing snowballs which looks to
be white chocolate pretzel m m's pretzel
m m's are so good before i had them i
was like who cares they're so good and
this one is just a white chocolate sugar
cookie holy [ __ ]
it tastes like i know sounds stupid but
it tastes exactly like a sugar cookie
these are really good this caught me by
surprise i've never even heard of this i
saw it at target i had to get it and
show it to you guys sour patch kids
extreme cookie chalet cookie house no
sir chalet look at this thing this is
either delicious or terrible either way
i love it good call this one sour patch
kids i love it so many other candy
brands are featuring various holiday
specials we couldn't cover them all so a
few others you might want to check out
are york peppermint patties dove hershey
kisses blow pops tootsie rolls rolos
cadbury they're all doing something for
christmas there's also a few holiday
sodas two specific holiday sodas are
this the mountain dew gingerbread
snapped soda and one i connected my
hands on was the spiced cranberry sprite
cranberry sprite sounds actually pretty
nice gingerbread mountain dew does not
it's not bad i'm not gonna lie it's
growing on me
yeah so it's just okay it's just okay my
adorable kids right here
look at this
[Applause]
a famous japanese chocolate brand called
chiro choco has two christmas exclusives
[Applause]
and this one too open it up
[Applause]
all right so this is chirolo choco and
it's so christmassy look at this
how cute you are so adorable it's got
white chocolate
not only white chocolate but they've got
milk chocolate
strawberry chocolate coffee chocolate
and white chocolate and something else
yeah
and merry christmas for you thank you
for watching happy holidays
christmas jokes with harry why did the
turkey join the band
he already had the drumsticks what do
polar bears like to eat
iceberg is
who hides in the bakery at christmas
mint spies
hello guys i'm george japan thank you
for watching and i wish you all merry
christmas that's it guys
merry christmas